- All right y'all.
We've hit the moment in the show,
when I share something utterly
delightful from social media,
this is What I'm Liking.
(upbeat music)
I want to introduce you to
the World's Perfect Toddler.
Seriously, she actually holds
that title after competing in
the World's Perfect
Pageant and Model Search
last month in Orlando.
But it's not her title that's
made her a viral sensation.
It's this moment, when
days after her competition,
two and a half year old
Abrianna stole the show,
hopping on stage during
the teenager competition.
She wasn't done yet, y'all.
We have little Abri out
on the line right now,
along with her momma,
Deborah, what's up ladies?
- Hi.
- Oh my gosh.
You are so cute.
Oh my God. Well Debra, Abrianna
is a little star, obviously.
So how many pageants has she been in?
- Well she started last
March. We put her in there.
She has held
to total
titles.
And
she is actually one of four of my kids.
She is the only girl.
So I wanted to do something
super girly with her.
I was really tired of playing
zombies and sword fighting.
So I thought, why not?
This will be fun. And
she fell in love with it.
- [Kelly] Oh my God I love.
- Never whined.
- That's me. That's me.
That's me.
Okay so, Deborah you
say pageants bring out
an entirely different side of her, right?
- Yes.
She is really shy in person.
Like
she
has a completely different personality
when she hit the stage.
Her confidence is just amazing.
- That's me!
That's you and
- [Kelly] And here's
the, look at that twirl.
- And she basically just,
she watches all the older girls from,
you know, all the pageants
and I'll type it in on YouTube,
like Miss USA, Catwalk, all that stuff.
And she just picks and
chooses what she wants.
And she will put it on stage
in whatever order she wants.
And Kristen Weaver, the
woman that posted the video,
that was a judge at
World's Perfect Pageant.
She's the one who captured all of that.
- Oh my God. The fact here's the thing.
You win an award right now for
even being able to hold down,
keeping conversation
going. (audience laughs)
That's amazing.
And I just want to do this
cause I've been trying to
wave at her the whole time.
So I'm Abrianna, what is your
favorite part of pageants?
That part? I get it.
It's getting that gold,
It's digging for that gold.
Yeah.
You're going for the gold. I get it.
I got you. Oh my gosh.
Thank you so much Abrianna and Deborah,
I'm liking your post right now.
That's not all though.
Our season long partner Pilot Pen,
the go-to pen of the Kelly
Clarkson Show wants to honor
ultimate overachievers,
just like you little bit.
So they'll be using their G2
Gel Ink Pen to write you a
check for $1,000. How's that sound?
(audience applause)